je suis fatigué ben bon jour mais s'il
avait avec nous le stylo votre session
recommence mardi
dites moi quels sont les grandes
priorités de votre gouvernement pour les
prochains mois jusqu'au quand je dis on
parle de santé aux publications robe
l'environnement et l'économie
ça va savoir s'accrocher à son nouvel
environnement on est très proches l'un
de l'autre et développe un peu mais qui
évidemment était important parce que
notre mandat mission ma mission c'est
quelle richesse collective il faut qu'on
peut justement réinvestir l'an nouveau
pilier sociétaux qui sont la santé 10
kasumi l'environnement l'économie y en a
qui disent des fois si ça fonctionne pas
de pair monsieur legault a dit il faut
que ça fonctionne il faut qu'on puisse
protéger l'environnement sans
nécessairement compromettre les
investissements
je pense à des projets comme à gnl par
exemple comment vous vous réconcilier
votre désir de stimuler l'économie tout
en protégeant l'environnement comme sur
le gouvernement n'ont d'ailleurs même
site le politique je pense que le
toujours dit que on est tous les
environnements
tous ont fait surface au changement j'en
connais des contradictions par contre
vous avez raison mais je pense que
fondamentalement tous les ministres et
moi particulièrement je pense l'économie
vont se nourrir de l'environnement j'ai
annoncé les trois gamins descendre pour
stimuler appel d'offres une vingtaine au
logis c'était le carbone transports
innovants
nouveau carburant je pense qu'on est on
est d'ailleurs et je dirais que la
roumanie a c'est l'environnement
l'économie et la wii et des processus de
battre par exemple des projets qu'il
faut pas savoir mais moins dans mon
corps et de plusieurs projets je
travaille avec monsieur chaleur puis je
suis parfaitement à l'aise le passé des
processus du bape mais je pense là
dessus on sait que les projets que nous
regardons à l'origine sont regardés en
collaboration avec l'environnement et
non pas à la fête pour un processus
qu'on voudrait l'aja a posteriori autre
est a priori vous le faites et
pathétiquement vous fait quoi si vous
arrivez vous étudiez projet vous êtes
c'est bon pour l'économie mais c'est
moins bon pour l'environnement mais moi
je le veux ce projet-là entend garder
connu fait quoi généralement pas le
gérer ce principalement on est en lutte
et focalisé sur soi alors je pense que
si on un projet qui va être gs négatif
donc on en est mais bien il faut
peut-être avoir après l'assaut et
programmes pour atténuer c'est le projet
récemment on a fait ça on a gardé un
projet c'était négatif au nouveau gm on
habite à côté
la captation qui a band qui va être fait
en concomitance pour neutraliser
je pense que des technologies les
techniques peuvent mettant en place pour
atténuer environnement et en bout de
piste il faut garder une base globale
nationale parce qu'ils vont à des
projets qui vont être négatif mais si on
en europe 1 par exemple j'aurais
beaucoup sur le véhicule électrique
peut-être réduit la moitié dont grc sont
émis par les véhicules électriques
seront compensées peut-être des projets
qui industriel qu'on doit faire
peut-être pour une pérennité de
certaines industries reprise des travaux
reprise de session et gagner mon prêt
toujours facile il ya eu certes un
volte-face certain cafouillage
est ce que vous avez appris de ces
moments là qu'est ce que vous vous dites
a tant que groupe parlementaire quand
vous retournez au gouvernement quand
vous retournez en chambre poser les
choses on est un jeune gouvernement je
suis jeune ministre hamad a parfaitement
fait des erreurs c'est sûr on à qui on
veut bien faire on va aller vite mais je
pense que le plus important c'est qu'on
réalise des fois qu'on faut s'ajuster
je pense que réaliser qu'on fait une
erreur l'écologie basse et salades à
midi
moi je peux pas du tout mal à l'aise par
rapport à ceux au contraire tous les nos
ministres mes collègues me suggéra
désert alors si on est solidaire je
pense que tu as un groupe qui est très
enthousiaste sur l'impact qu'on pense
avoir sur le québec
bon allons d'investissement québec ça
c'est ça c'est vous c'est dans votre
dans votre cour vous en occuper demain
vous allez vous à les relancer
investissement québec cette dernière
étape du processus de transition à quoi
on peut s'attendre à ce que je retenais
un peu en arrière je pense pourquoi on
fait l'effort d'investissement
j'ai toujours dit qu'ils estiment à
québec ce qu'il faisait dans le passé tu
es bien fait c'est ce qu'il ne faisait
pas qui était un problème pour moi
on regarde le fondamental de notre
croissance économique développement
économique ça passe par trois os
l'innovation parce que nous sommes sûrs
productifs au québec par rapport à nos
compétiteurs ontariens et américains
on veut plus d'exportations parce que
nous avons une balance commerciale
déficitaire
puis on veut plus d'investissements
directs étrangers pertinent pour nourrir
à peine sourire alors investi 3,7 l
ajustement venait même à québec les
outils financiers et humains pour
couvrir les trois acteurs à quelle
vitesse vous voulez voir des résultats
on y voit court terme c'est ce nombre
inclut générationnel mais si je parle
aux véhicules électriques natation
d'egypte batterie par exemple se
reprendre de se reprendre
puis josé nord il était entre-temps on
commence à prendre et déjà avant même
que le projet de loi soit approuvée
on commence à prendre une rouste de
risque dangereuse de nice ça fait partie
de la réflexion actuellement que vous
avez imposées investissement québec
evans est davantage de risques dans une
banque j'oserais de joundallah hockey au
québec les bateaux tout cela il faut un
bon travail
alors c'est important qu'un
investissement québec dans la chaîne des
capitaux soit en complémentarité de ce
qui existe comprenez des risques qu'ils
prenaient avec l'argent des
contribuables se fasse et la vente aux
québécois je pense qu'il faut avoir une
moyenne au bâton qui est adéquat
alors à tous de risque et se garder des
investissements qui sont moins bons mais
on va peut-être faire des rames en sur
d'autres investissements qui vont
contrecarrer ces pertes d'eau et peut
même faire plus encore une fois je pense
que faut mesurer aussi les impacts mais
l'important c'est qu'on mesure pour les
packs d'investissement québec seulement
sur le capital investi sur les
répercussions sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
les répercussions sur la compétivité des
entreprises parce qu'une des raisons
pourquoi on sue exporte parce qu'on
était sous productif donc en réglant
l'innovation en entreprise
on est capable de rehausser de niveau
compétition peut s'exporter espèces des
investissements publics par bombardier
la compagnie où airbus l'avait le groupe
airbus canada voudrait vous voir
investir davantage dans l'avion chez
legault a dit qu'il n'en était pas
question
quelle est la solution qu'est ce que
vous allez faire pas vraiment les
objectifs du gouvernement sont très
claires
au programme du à 220 c'est un excellent
programme on veut que le programme
fonctionne on peut questionner le côté
financier à l'origine ça c'est clair
c'est un enjeu il sont en garde le futur
première chose c'est qu'il faut se tirer
pour que le milliard de dollars investis
qu'on est la plus grande valeur possible
ce meilleur ça va pas très bien
la deuxième jour venir sa deuxième des
emplois on a présentement au de 2500
emplois sont liés ou à 220 chiffre qui
pourrait augmenter ses taux la gamme va
aussi bien qu'on pense qu'il va aller
maintenant la structure financière
notamment monsieur lebon à juste titre
mentionné que nous avons mis un milliard
us dans le programme c'est suffisant
pour l'argent des québécois
tout le monde est d'accord d'autres
façons de travailler avec airbus et
airbus nous voulons qu'il soit heureux
et au québec on veut airbus qui vont
travailler conjointement avec nous
autres pour augmenter le programme le
programme à 220 est important pour
airbus
programme à 220 été créés au québec le
sens nerveux du royal et si votre
demeure et ici il faut soutenir
financièrement l'entreprise pour que
nous n'étions pas d'argent mais en même
temps qu'on protège des milliards il ya
de grands comptes puis à terme le québec
récupère son investissement était fort
garde est l'investissement du milliard
d'une base très large si on regarde les
investissements du milan on va savoir ce
même en 4 5 1 quelle est la vraie valeur
du billard parce qu'honnêtement c'est
beaucoup d'hypothèses de programmes et
en début de vie le prix de l'avion est
très sensible sur la valeur les
personnes qui sait aujourd'hui qu'elle
voit des prix de la viande de trois ans
alors je pense que je peux m'engager des
programmes vont être très rentable pas
rentable nous ne savons pas c'est
important par contre ce que le programme
fonctionne et l'emploi et les bénéfices
collatéraux sur sam ans à 3 à 4000
emplois à mirabel paroisse de 120
l'édifice fut énorme énorme pour les
recettes fiscales énorme pour notre
rayonnement international
la gamme industrielle vous c'est du
rendement sur le milliard humains et
investir et vous vous donnez combien de
temps pour déterminer ce que vous allez
faire de ce côté octet externe
bombardier doit
lui et ses résultats donc moi je pense
que d'ici deux semaines n'aura pas de
clarté sur ce côté de l'équation on va
dire votre collègue monsieur girard
cette semaine à l'essai en tant que les
choses allaient mieux que ce qu'ils
avaient anticipé que la croissance
économique était meilleur que ce que
vous aviez pendant si c'est vrai et à
quel point c'est un éveil pas que je
pense que le message passe passe quand
on parle de récession c'est un terme
ce pack est révolue mais je pense qu'on
est tous d'accord dans la communauté que
c'est à dire pas de récession majeure
parce qu'il est juste de dire que les
surplus budgétaires que nous avons
présentement m'ont vraiment diminué
indiquent sans viande je pense est clair
et ont déjà au travail déjà cette année
avec une rigueur financière qui pourrait
démontrer un certain dan asthme
je pense que nous avons les moyens de
nos ambitions et mosci mexes beaucoup ce
que nous avons dû moyens d'investir dans
l'innovation s'assurer pendant cette
période difficile pour continuer vers
c'est parce que j'ai rien péter
d'arrêter d'investir quand on pense aux
vallées manche le rhône accents dessus
pour les matière de compétitivité alors
présentement j'ai des moyens financiers
au québec et aux mises à l'économie pour
soit passé au niveau économique
ça va être plus dur dans les prochaines
années c'est sûr je pense qu'une bonne
position et la diversification
économique qu'ont au québec elle est à
nos portes
nous être bruder on voit la conscience
plus forte au québec quand même
l'impression que la marge de manoeuvre
que vous avez avec investissement québec
vous permet à certains égards un
stimulant l'investissement d'atténuer
peut-être l'impact du ralentissement
d'un registre effectivement je pense que
si on est capable d'être plus compétitif
donc de plus exporter on est capable à
ce moment là d'avoir une meilleure
nutrition des cycles c'est sûr que quand
un cycle baissier mondial tout le monde
paye mais généralement le tour des
fenêtres d'opportunité qui sont là on
parle de libre échange au québec on est
privilégiés nous avons trois accords de
libre échange
celui que les studios du mexique celui
que l'europe qu'on n'a pas réellement
j ai travaillé à grand public la zee là
au québec et on a dit on a des moyens
qui sont à jour en six ans pour la
laurent du libre échange
le débat se déroule présentement à
ottawa sur l'accord de libre échange
canada etats unis mexique les problèmes
pour le bloc du côté de l'aluminium est
ce que vous vous voyez un problème de ce
côté là où ailleurs dans l'accord de
libre échange à quelle vitesse vous
voulez que ce soit de l'aluminium j'ai
passé johnny socialisme penser il a deux
semaines pour réactiver la filiale
d'aluminium une baisse à tj c'est clair
qu'on veut on veut promouvoir le pli
mais je pense que l'aluminium va
combattre au québec qui est vaudois va
vous être recherchée très bientôt payer
une prime j'espère un jour l'aluminium
seconde assure secondaire ou sur rendez
vous bon c'est sûr qu'on ne touche pas
du camping on parle on a une certaine
assurance madame africaine madame joly
qui j'ai parlé ont une assurance que les
républicains démocrates reçues ni
réaliste de la situation du dumping
n'est pas désirable dans le dakar sap
est imminent l'accord est en progression
on n'a rien à voir mais en même temps je
pense qu'il faut rapidement faire ça
colle à monsieur legault t'aiderai de la
wii on a même l'impression peut le faire
après l'accord je pense qu'il faut aussi
d'accord on a besoin pour nos échanges
commerciaux j'ai terminé là dessus mais
l'autre risque duquel on parle beaucoup
c'est le cas en à virus et qui était
déclaré
une urgence de santé mondiale par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
à quel point est-ce que ça préoccupe ça
de votre point de vue l'impact que cela
pourrait avoir sur les qualités on n'est
pas que je vous rappelle que ça j'étais
encore quand son style jésuite oriella
bord et ça c'est mieux et n'est pas que
portant sur relation n'est pas que là
encore avec d'autres pays dont la chine
ni le québec est quand même sako
commerciaux importants c'est sûr qu'il
va y avoir un impact et moins voyagent
mans alors y avoir une et deux sens des
gens vont être plus nerveux
je pense qu'on en est conscient et je
pense que la chine va faire on est pas
beaucoup de la chine parce qu'on exporte
maintenant des recettes commerciales
je pense que c'est préoccupant mais
c'est encore prématuré je pense qu'on
commence à regarder une compagnie de
combat et nous on parle un peu aussi
mais je programmatique lesquels face aux
belges ou étudient le transit du solde
de voyager donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
moyens financiers pour voter nuit
peut-être certaines pertes mais on est
très très très embryonnaire
je pense que des contrôles aux jeux le
ministre merci beaucoup